Everyone.
How are you?
Monday?
Monday lunchtime.
We awake.
Yeah.
Hello.
Uh,
Indiana,
thank you so much for being here and sharing with us at Google.
Um,
we could not be more thrilled and as you can see,
you got a huge lunchtime crowd coming out.
I only see empty.
I'm only lean focusing on the MTC.
It's where are those people that my manager hates me because whenever I play,
I'll play like a packed house and I'll say to people in the front that just
probably their kid got sick and then couldn't make.
And I'm like,
what did we sell those two fucking seats in the front?
He's like,
I did.
I swear to God,
I hate it.
Just makes me insecure.
Anyway,
his,
sorry.
Am I allowed to curse?
I go,
yeah.
Yeah,
you're good.
Uh,
this is an adult audience,
so we're good.
Nobody's here's ever curse in their whole life.
See it now.
Um,
so thank you for coming.
You have a new album out.
Uh,
and one that is,
I think somebody has told me deeply personal to you and we'd love to lead off
there of sort of your journey.
And,
and sort of what led you to this album?
I had most people's albums deeply personal.
I mean everybody asks me that,
which,
and it is,
it's true,
but,
um,
I dunno.
It's like whose album isn't,
who's the album do with love that isn't deeply per right.
Right,
right.
One would hope,
but,
um,
uh,
but mine is,
I know,
um,
yeah,
I dunno.
I,
you know,
the last three or four years,
no,
about three years I guess.
Um,
I,
I had like a lot of,
um,
conflicting dynamics,
I guess you could say.
I,
um,
the simultaneously going through a divorce while frozen was going on its whole
crazy trajectory.
So I literally would go from singing at the Oscars to heading to a mediation
agreement discussing like visitation about my son,
you know,
so,
um,
it was just professionally speaking and an incredible time and personally
speaking,
you know,
very complicated.
So,
um,
I had a lot to,
to write about and um,
it just felt like a good time to get back in the studio and,
you know,
put it into some music.
Awesome.
Um,
I thank you for going there so early in the Carson.
He was amazing.
Um,
uh,
and you know,
as you were sort of building the album as well and just being the theater geek
than I am,
I'm thinking about the time in place.
We are in theater right now with what's happened with Hamilton,
what we're seeing in sort of transformative and you've really been a part of
some of the most transformative shows in theater period.
Um,
everybody rent,
right and right.
There's the applause.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
and not to mention wicked.
Uh,
yeah,
there we go.
Just to right there and I do one every 10 years,
one Zike guys kind of project every 10 years.
And um,
the rest I,
I,
I starve and I'm going to spirity and then all of a sudden I get a job and it's
like,
oh,
that's a big deal.
And then I'm back on top again.
But uh,
you basically just drop the mic constantly.
I wish I was cool enough to actually do a mic drop like that,
but,
um,
no,
I've been really,
really lucky.
But I also have experienced the ebb and flow of this industry,
which I think is why I'm able to really enjoy when those moments happen because
I,
I know how fleeting they can be.
And um,
you know,
so I'm,
I actually,
um,
more than ever can like,
get onstage and I'm taking the moment and realize how lucky I am and who knows
what's going to happen tomorrow.
And wow,
people showed up and you know,
but that,
that all started with my first professional experience,
which was rent and that entire mindset of our composer passing away on the night
of our,
first of our,
I think it was our invited dress,
which is like the night before an audience.
Um,
actually it was,
no,
it was the first preview cause there wasn't no invited dress.
Yeah.
Um,
anyway,
so when your career starts with that kind of,
um,
uh,
event,
it kind of dictates how you,
how you see this industry and your art and um,
gives you a perspective.
Um,
and I was lucky cause we were at a young age that that happened and we could
have like lost perspective and objectivity.
But instead of getting caught up in all of the magazines and the accolades,
our cast actually I've never worked in any show that this has ever happened
since.
Um,
we didn't miss not one person,
Mr Show for six at least six months,
um,
eight shows a week singing at the top of our lungs because we were so committed
to whether we were sick or not to getting up there and making sure we put out
his message,
you know,
it was just,
that was the most important thing.
Wow,
that's amazing.
Um,
and with that,
I hadn't even thought about that actually in the context of that question,
um,
before them and when you talked about the ebbs and flows and obviously that was
both again,
at the same time,
that sort of trajectory,
which we about actually up top
with your album now as well.
The sort of the conflicting of motions of the high and the low at the same time,
which is the same thing that happened with rent up to that point,
which is the stuff we can't really Google is before rent.
Well,
you know what,
what was the seed that got planted in you wanting to do theater or wanting to
sing all the time?
What was that driving force for you that led you to that sort of first big
professional moment of rent that you feel prepared you for,
you know,
or did it?
Oh yeah,
there are different ones.
It's Kinda like saying what your first love was.
Was it the,
the kid in kindergarten that like kissed you on the cheek or is it the guy who
first said sex with,
I mean,
which like what's first love really,
right.
So,
um,
that's a really bad example.
Okay.
We're just getting real here.
But I do,
I always think about that.
It's like when people say first level,
I think I really loved this kid,
Evan Beller when I was in kindergarten,
but certainly didn't let him go up my shirt or anything.
Do you know what I mean?
So,
mmm.
Is it early?
It's a really,
I'm just,
I think I'm tired of the album came out this week and I,
I've been like surprising drag shows and gay clubs at midnight.
And I'm like,
I dunno what times that when I'm on.
Um,
so you're going to get me a little delirious and stick foot directly into mouth.
what was the question again?
Oh,
uh,
oh yeah,
first like moment.
Right.
Um,
well,
yeah.
So my point being,
it could either be when my,
my gram,
father,
Nathan,
um,
Grandpa Nat,
you know,
would put a fake toy microphone in my hand when I was five and do shows with me
and the living room or a,
it could be when I sang at this a talent show,
um,
we're up in the Catskills where the Jews all go.
Um,
and uh,
it was a family trip and our parents sent us to the day camp when we did a
little talent show and I sang the way we were with a full on long island accent
and,
but everybody's percolating,
you know,
there people turn to my parents and said,
oh,
she could be special,
you know,
so like,
I don't know.
There is,
there's those times.
Um,
and that was about theater.
Yeah.
Oh,
it could have been the time where my grandmother took me to see a star is born
with Barbra Streisand and Chris Christopherson.
That kind of changed my life,
that idea of being put on a stage and having a win over an audience of people
that were booing you and being so good and captivating that that stopped them
all in their tracks.
Something like that about that was amazing to me.
And then,
um,
parents got divorced when I was teenager and,
my was dating this,
this cool guy that really believed in me a lot and said,
you should write music.
And,
um,
knew some guy that was in the wedding bar Mitzvah,
seen in long island.
Um,
and,
and helped me lie about my age because I was 15 and illegally driving to all of
these gigs and got me a Gig with Tony Syeda and the Echos in ocean side.
And,
um,
and I knew like three songs.
Um,
it was what a feeling from flashdance evergreen and like,
um,
I forget that song,
like the Sunshine Song.
Um,
anyway,
I can't think.
But,
um,
and then I,
and I started doing weddings and bar Mitzvahs and having to learn all of this
music.
And it was like an education for me.
I had to learn like Motown and Aretha and jazz,
Billie holiday and Ella Fitzgerald and all of a sudden then I didn't want to
necessarily do theater.
I wanted to be like a rock star.
So I went back and forth between Annie when I was little and Peter Pan and then
wanting to write my music and record and all that.
And so it's been a constant dance for me even till this day sitting here with
you trying to get people to accept me,
my desire to cross over from the theater and be,
uh,
have integrity as a rock or a pop singer,
songwriter.
Um,
it's just followed me this little
mmm
dance,
trying to straddle both places and be accepted in both.
And do you feel like,
um,
that's really,
by the way,
I'm just picturing you sitting at bar and Bat Mitzvahs like in my head.
Uh,
and did you feel like with this album and sort of,
you know,
even just looking at the track list and people's comments sort of really picking
up on your pop track in a real way,
like the intentionality of there,
of all the genre crossing because of your influences,
um,
sort of what was your thought process there and what do you hope,
like as we all listen to the album,
what we hear from you,
um,
as part of that journey?
Yeah.
Thanks for asking that.
Um,
what's funny though,
I've done a couple albums before this that it meant more to me the sole
crossover thing and it didn't happen.
I got dropped or I sold like three albums or whatever.
So at this point in my life,
so many things have happened that,
um,
that I'm proud of and I get up on stage and I do a concert and it's,
I cry,
I,
the setlist is a,
is a chronology of my life,
of the songs in my life.
And some of it's defying gravity from wicked.
And some of it's an old Joni Mitchell song cause it inspired me.
And then there's let it go from frozen,
and then there's original music.
And I used to worry that that was confusing in some way and didn't have the
cohesion.
But now I realize the cohesion,
the common denominator is me and all of my experiences and I'm almost,
you know,
and I'm 45 years old and this is,
this is who I am is the life I've led.
And so I gotta stop trying to worry.
I got to stop worrying about it,
you know?
And,
um,
so when I went in the studio this time,
I picked producers that I love that,
that have worked with people that I really admire.
But once we got in there,
we just wrote music and hung out and recorded.
And,
and I,
I stopped worrying about that.
All I cared about was that they,
um,
they supported me being honest and trying different things and,
and,
um,
but what I think has happened is it is,
it has a really cool current,
mainstream kind of sound.
And so,
you know,
hopefully,
uh,
I just want to expand my audience really.
That's all right.
Love that.
And it's,
it's really interesting also sort of given the context,
interestingly of this sort of groundbreaking theater,
you've been a part of that sort of bent also,
what is theater on what the music is that is in theater.
And I thinking about rent and in rock,
um,
and you know,
wicked really taking us into like full Broadway,
big belt number,
you know,
and thinking even about the trajectory of theater itself right now.
Um,
you know,
with Hamilton and a lot of experimenting happening and also with the advent of
digital,
I mean we're here at Google and thinking about all the artists that are sort of
genre crossing because there's no box you have to like,
exactly.
And we'd have more control as artists.
We can put our selves in south promote.
We don't have to rely just on our label understanding us.
We can reconstruct,
contrast the public to just want to hear music,
love music.
And like so many of the theater vans I have,
they're amazing music,
um,
efficient autos.
You know,
they,
they love music.
They're not just theater kids.
They love everything.
They just love good music and good writing.
So,
um,
why not just put it out there and let,
let the people find it?
You know?
So that's really empowering for artists now to not back in the day when I was
trying to,
you know,
get a record deal and playing down at the bitter end and in the village,
and it was all about just getting a record deal and the label and being accepted
by these people and now,
you know,
as long as you can tour,
which is the most important thing to me to be able to make a paycheck and go out
and sing and on a stage for people,
then I have the power back,
which is exciting.
It's amazing.
I mean I feel like if I took a poll right now with the audience,
how many of you are just obsessed with this woman's voice in general?
Right,
exactly.
I think your voice,
not to say defy,
but it does defies like any particular giant,
no,
the pun was too easy.
Um,
but it,
it,
it really does defy any particular genre.
I think we all,
you just started at,
we're all obsessed with your voice.
And what you're bringing is an artist.
So I think in that way,
this is,
well my,
um,
I've been working with,
I'm a voice teacher for over 20 years.
Um,
she's not the kind of teacher that you would think.
I before her,
when I was younger,
I studied classically,
you know,
but,
um,
that might start listening to all of the other music.
I thought,
well,
I don't want to sound like that,
you know,
like a lot of,
um,
people sound when they've been overly trained and then they try to sing soulful
music or whatever.
Um,
and hers restorative,
um,
hers,
her technique is actually the untraining,
this sort of,
I mean,
she prepares me how to breathe and keep my voice so I can do eight shows a week
and I hurt myself and I can build my range and all of that stuff.
So we definitely have a regiment that I can explain if that anybody's interested
in that.
But the point being is about singing from a place of speaking as opposed to
like,
you know,
doesn't sound like any of us talk.
Right?
So,
not nothing against that kind of singing,
but my particular,
um,
you know,
what I gravitate to is coming from speaking,
even if it's the way I would yell at you on a playground if I was a kid.
That's just my higher part of my voice.
But it all comes from how we would communicate,
you know,
as humans is real,
our real voice.
And so,
and I believe that that's what makes people sound people,
gives people,
gives an audience a real connection to somebody because they're really talking
and not performing over producing the s the sound.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I dunno why I told you that.
I forget what you said.
No,
that's perfect because we were just having a conversation.
So here we are.
So sorry,
I keep taking the coffee.
It's not really helping.
I'm just like,
no,
it's a,
maybe it is helping and I'm just like,
why buy buy,
buy,
buy.
I know.
It's amazing.
I think everybody's had wrapped like sort of just shaking their head in
agreement with you that relate-ability.
Um,
and like you were saying earlier,
this sort of artifice between you and the audience has sort of disappeared in so
many ways that that connection of what you're talking about really singing in a
way that's accessible
to human speaking.
Yeah.
The only thing working against that is that
we are,
we all listen to music that's been fixed and auto tune so much that now what is
perfect and imperfect is,
uh,
can be debated.
And when you go to a live concert,
are you really hearing people are not?
And so when you actually hear someone that's chooses to actually sing,
even when she has a bad cold or it's that time a month or she was up at three in
the morning where their son or fighting with her boyfriend and I don't sound
perfect,
it's,
uh,
it's caused a lot of,
um,
it's taken some of the love out of it.
For me,
the social takes a lot out of it because,
because I read it like an asshole.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
that people can just go on there and immediately talk about everything.
And so,
um,
it's,
it's made,
it,
it's made it harder to enjoy it.
I have to really kind of like turn it off and find the love of singing and also
remember that
there have been many shows where I've sung and not been top of my game and
people still are in tears,
are still feel something.
And I remember,
oh,
it's not because I had a really high note that makes someone feel something.
It's cause you're,
what you're communicating is a person.
So I have to remember that,
but my whole life has been about,
my entire identity has been based on the fact that when I was a young girl,
I had this voice.
And so as I've gotten older I've had to understand that,
you know,
I have a lot more to offer the world and just being a singer.
And,
um,
but sometimes I,
I forget that myself.
Well,
it also comes from even the earlier days you were saying,
um,
you were sort of taught to think about songwriting early,
very early on,
which,
um,
I would imagine has actually helped in terms of thinking beyond just where the
pigeon holes might be,
you know,
with people thinking about you.
And,
and with that W,
were there any for you like defining moments in your career,
either joyous or really tough.
I know we talked about a bit about rent,
but have there been any other moments for you that just really stand out as an
artist or maybe in a moment that you suddenly felt like you had defined maybe
one of those boxes that somebody had maybe put you in?
Um,
yeah.
Well,
the success of let it go and frozen because,
um,
you said like with rent that it was this rock pop musical and you would think
that then that would open doors for me to be able to walk,
uh,
between all of these lines.
But it wasn't,
whenever I'd go into a recording studio with a big time producer songwriter,
they'd sort of admonished me and say like,
Oh,
you're too expressive.
Yeah.
It's all that Broadway training,
you know,
are we,
you have to sound more like Sheryl Crow,
throw it away,
you know?
And then,
um,
and,
and so,
I'm sorry,
I lost my train of thought.
So then,
um,
helped me is defining moments where you sort of broke the box.
Yeah.
And so they would have all of these rules like theater people never,
you know,
never going to get on the radio on a pop station and then all of us and cut to
like 15 years later,
I'm like taking my kids to school and z 100 on,
I hear let it go.
I'm like,
what the hell?
You know,
you just can't,
you can't worry about those rules.
And I did for a long time and you just got to keep moving and going and taking
work that makes you feel good and surround yourself with people that,
you know,
that teacher stuff just keep going because the trends and the rules,
they always break.
And move and change.
And I'm all of a sudden you hear like a bridge,
like what,
what's the bridge in?
And let it goes.
Like I'm frozen fractals all around and it's like this crazy lyrics would never
be in a pop song that fractals,
fractals,
not me,
I didn't write it,
but like,
you know,
so,
but it's become like this huge pop culture moment,
you know,
so go figure and fuck all those people that like wrote me off.
So you know,
that's a big,
that was a big defining moment,
a teaching moment for me just to know.
You just,
you can't keep following a trend because by the time you get there,
it's changed already.
So just keep doing your thing.
Um,
um,
this album's a big deal just cause you know,
when you're,
I was with my,
my ex husband for were married a long time,
but together even longer,
so like 16 years and grew up together.
And um,
so to figure out how to separate yourself,
who you are separate from that person and um,
to be creative without worrying about what he would think,
um,
was interesting.
Um,
and liberating too,
to just get in the studio and go and not worry.
Um,
and figuring out how to stop regretting all of that stuff and pave the way for
some new exciting stuff to happen.
You know,
I got engaged recently.
Ooh,
you regulations.
Thanks.
Um,
and with that,
just thinking,
I mean even about let it go and this sort of in the new album and when,
where that came from the journey.
Um,
I think,
you know,
at least from what I've seen and I work a lot on,
on inclusion issues and representation issues as part of my day job.
Um,
yeah,
I was just in the bathroom stall and there's a thing about inclusion as I was
sitting on the toilet.
Yeah,
you've put a thing in front of me about inclusion,
learning on the loo,
learning on the loo.
Okay.
Got It.
I was reading it,
it was effective if somebody in here who did that fantastic Dni at Google.
Um,
and
you know,
the,
the fun part about that is we work with a lot of artists,
you know,
who are,
are viewed as role models in the industry and sort of as our friend Gina Davis
says,
if you can see it,
you can be it.
Um,
and given fro them,
you brought up frozen and let it go.
And now actually sort of defining yourself entirely in a,
in this way with the album and this new moment,
um,
who was a role model in your life and have you felt that that idea of a role
model fall on you now,
given how many little girls and boys,
you know,
kind of latched on to your music who may have not known you before,
what's that been like?
And,
and can you trace it to somebody in your own life?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
first of all,
my,
my sister's a huge role model for me.
She's my younger sister,
three and a half years younger than me,
but,
um,
she got married and had kids before me.
So our roles are reversed in a lot of ways.
I'd go to her for the wisdom of certain things.
And um,
she,
uh,
got remarried so she went through a bunch of crap and,
um,
handled it so gracefully and had these,
she was single and had these two little tiny boys at the time.
And because she grew up with a sister that was always like,
I know what I'm doing with my life.
I'm singing,
I want to be famous.
And she was like,
ah,
I have no idea what to do.
And I have this,
I knowing sister's shadow too,
to walk around.
And it took her longer to figure out what you want to do with their life.
And then she did.
She,
she's this amazing teacher and a writer is writing a book.
And um,
but she did it.
She went back to school and got her master's with the two little kids.
And so anyway,
just her strength and um,
grace really,
it's been a inspiration to me.
Super,
super smart and eloquent.
And,
um,
the role model thing with me and the characters I played and they're always
connecting to young audiences is,
is a beautiful thing.
And it's also daunting responsibility,
uh,
one is that there's,
the age disparity is getting even bigger and bigger.
So,
you know,
now I like the frozen thing and there's like six year olds and then there's me,
I'm coming.
So like I do a concert,
I'm on stage talking like a truck driver.
And then I looked down and there's just like a mom with a little girl in the
blue dress in front of me and I'm talking about how so and so on,
oh,
at my shirt and this,
you know,
so,
and then I realized,
Oh fuck,
you know,
like,
and then I do that.
And then it's like,
it's this constant mess.
So,
um,
and the manager's like,
could you please watch your mouth?
Are these young kids?
I'm like,
I got,
I made me.
And uh,
so it's hard,
you know,
also the,
there's that,
but then there's also the,
the part of just all these amazing characters I've gotten the play about like,
um,
you know,
young women finding their,
finding themselves,
embracing this thing and them that's super unique and beautiful,
but sort of looked down upon by society.
And then they finally harness it,
embrace it and do amazing things with that.
That whole idea,
um,
is great,
but it's not always who I am,
you know.
So I specifically put creep by Radiohead and my set last year when I was on tour
because it was an opportunity to sing a song about feeling completely despicable
and letting them know that like,
I don't always feel like letting it go or defying gravity.
It's not easy to wake up every day and sing songs like that and you shouldn't
have to,
sometimes you just want to feel really sorry for yourself and stay in bed and
that's okay too.
That's how I've been grappling with it.
Um,
that's awesome.
I just had this vision of you in bed and the creed song playing legs over.
Um,
and it's so real.
I think this is a true,
by the way,
with everybody we've talked to in that space is this sort of pressure to be on
for especially the little kids and,
and how to balance that with,
you know,
being a real human,
um,
and that may be showing them that you're a real human is actually even a more
impactful thing.
Yeah.
Um,
and with that,
you know,
in that vein,
just doing a little bit of research on you before this,
there was an some exciting,
real work that you've done with kids and also in the philanthropy and activism
space,
which I didn't want us to go without talking about cause it's so important.
Um,
weird factoid.
My high school was the first high school outside of the city of New York to
support Broadway cares,
equity fights,
AIDS in Marietta,
Georgia,
where Lgbtq rights were not very welcome at the time that we started collecting
donations.
And so I was particularly moved by your activism in that space.
So thank you.
Um,
and would love if you'd like to talk a little bit about what you've done and
what you've been working on.
Maybe what's to come in that space?
Well,
I was lucky enough as a kid,
my parents would send me away to sleep away camp.
You know,
it's,
it's a Jewish east coast thing to do.
And,
um,
it was a privileged thing.
And,
um,
but it was a wonderful experience and opportunity to escape,
to kind of rewrite yourself as a kid if you didn't enjoy your school year.
It's a place to bond and make new friends and
MMM.
Find yourself really.
And I always wanted to have a camp and then as I got older and I
mmm.
Started to have these experiences in these projects where it was connecting to
young women,
especially,
mmm.
Young women trying to find their voice,
I realized that the camp had to be more than just what I experienced when I was
younger and,
um,
be more meaningful than that.
And so my college roommate,
who's much smarter than me and was sick and tired of hearing me talk about this
dream pipe dream.
And so she galvanized the whole thing.
She's a business major lawyer,
you know,
type a personality.
He got the thing together and um,
it's called the broader way and it's ours.
We're going on our seventh year.
It's a 10 day program where we take a bunch of inner city girls,
mostly from Harlem and lower east side,
um,
up to the Berkshire Mountains in Massachusetts,
uh,
for days to like a college campus that we lease the property for now.
Eventually,
hopefully we'll have our own place.
Um,
and we sing and we dance and we swam.
And um,
Jenny into story who's like an incredible Broadway composer,
wrote fun home and ton of things.
She's kind of like my creative director and we bring up amazing veteran
performers that come and work with them.
But the whole thing is not to put on like Oklahoma with these girls.
It's um,
we encourage them to write a lot.
They do a lot of spoken word.
They write their own songs,
lyrics,
they choreograph their own movement.
Um,
and so at the end of the 10 days,
they come into back into New York to a theater that's usually thank thankfully
given to us for the night and we put on a recital concert.
If you will,
that's a complete,
um,
a collage of their,
their original work.
Um,
so it's,
um,
and so we started with 30 girls the first year and now it's become a four year
program.
And we've now at the point where our original girls came back and were a cit
yes.
Um,
only the ones that we felt were capable of doing that.
cause he's still are only 15.
So,
uh,
and yeah.
And so now we're up to like 80 girls or something and it's a,
it's a,
that's a huge responsibility.
Um,
and it's hard.
All the fundraising and all that stuff and also wanting to keep tabs on them
through the year because I always find even as adults when we're involved in
like a really amazing project and then we're finished,
we kind of crash,
you know,
and so imagine these girls who have these kind of shitty home life,
a lot of them,
and they go from this magical 10 days and then they go back in.
So I want to make sure they felt like,
you know,
it wasn't over and through the year we can,
can we do little reunions and when they go see shows together and we go see art
and,
um,
tap dance,
we have like dance things and whatever.
Anyway,
so it's a constant evolve,
constantly involving foundation,
want to get to the point where we have college funds for them and things like
that.
But that's all in the future.
That's amazing.
Thanks.
That's really awesome.
Um,
and um,
it just,
it gets me thinking also about,
um,
sort of this journey you were talking about earlier about role modeling because
in a way that's a place where you're becoming very human to them and them to
you.
And I think that's really awesome,
uh,
and remarkable.
Um,
and with that,
I want to do two more questions.
That'd be my mistake of not asking.
I would like to do some word association before we turn it over to the audience.
It should be fun.
Everybody,
especially given
that I'm said coffee.
Yeah.
Chuck.
Uh,
um,
and um,
and also,
um,
and then I had one more in here.
Oh,
before I do that.
Yeah.
What's the ones that we do work at Google?
What's the one thing that we couldn't Google search about you.
Okay.
Uh,
so there's a lot out there.
I know and I don't know,
um,
would you like us to know that you wouldn't normally talk about?
Because as you see,
I'm an open book,
so it's like I don't really high that much,
but
mmm.
Pretty much a slob.
I'm not dirty.
There's a difference between dirty and messy.
I don't like,
you know,
like oatmeal,
like left out for ANZ to eat.
I don't like that.
I like the counter to be cleaned,
but like my clothes are everywhere.
The bathroom's a mess.
The towels,
the things that,
um,
the beds hardly ever made and less people are coming over and I want to pretend
that it's clean.
Um,
yeah.
I love that.
By the way,
I also am messy and not dirty.
There is a distinct difference.
Yeah.
I shower,
yeah,
the time.
Thank God Harris Clean.
I just don't like putting things in way.
I'm not very organized.
If you take anything away from here.
We both showered today.
Yes.
But we don't make the bed and showered last night and this morning brushed my
teeth even.
Wow.
Which is a lot for a mother who by the way got up,
my son was slept at Dad's last night but he couldn't take them to school this
morning and I didn't want the nanny to do that cause I had enough time so I got
up,
made his lunches because dad never makes us good lunch.
I do.
And then um,
drove over there,
which is 10 minutes away completely in my pajamas.
Didn't brush my teeth,
rolled out of bed yet.
I did it on Friday and the Paparazzi got a picture of me doing that,
which was really nice.
Um,
I was dropping him off at Dad's and they said I was going to daycare Brit
dropping him off at daycare and it was actually his house.
It was taste house is like,
I'm like get your facts straight like I'm for anyway.
What was I saying?
So Oh like,
so I was just a mass this morning and the lunch is the thing.
Got Him to school 10 minutes late.
Every mom at the schools like perfectly quaffed with like three kids and a job,
I don't know.
And me and like Amy Poehler or like we both go to the school and she's the only
one I know.
Like she'll roll out of,
I could tell she rolled out of bed and a PJ's and got the kid to school like
within a second of being late.
And I'm like,
thank God for Amy because these other moms are so annoying.
Respect,
respect that.
I see some heads nodding in the room.
Yes.
We all love that.
We'd been there right on.
Oh,
I see some hands.
You got to sleep in like cool sweatpants that were the Lego cool rock and roll
boot.
Looks like you meant it,
but you just slept in your,
where'd the PJ's to school?
Put on the cool boot and it's like you meant to happen that isn't protips.
Yes.
Yeah.
And only have one kid.
Tammy's mom's have three,
so I don't know.
And they're skinny.
You know what I mean?
That's outlay man.
That like we can't explain it and explain that.
I'm telling you and then you can you work and all you want to do is eat a Bagel.
I go,
I'm like,
can we please,
I know that's like the minute I get there,
I have to order from this deli.
I've always,
or I still know that phone number by by heart do through 909 three three,
seven,
three.
It's big along the Corner Deli.
I like,
it's crazy.
I have to have a Bagel,
cream cheese,
a black and white cookie.
It's like going to the movies and you have to have popcorn as students.
I get to New York gets what I have anyway.
I'm sorry.
It's that.
No,
no.
Did we all write down that number?
I feel like that was a really good bagel wreck.
If for al of us here,
we have a huge New York office,
so this is actually great.
Um,
and so with that,
before we turn it over to the audience,
I'm sure there's a lot of burning questions.
A quick word.
Association.
One word.
First one that pops in your mind.
You're ready?
No.
Okay.
Progress.
Uh Oh,
this is how I'm going to be honest.
That's not the name of my boyfriend.
Fiance.
I hate that word.
His name's Aaron progress.
I don't know why he popped in.
I think cause he's,
he's um,
okay.
Yeah,
cause I think he makes me a better person.
He's a used to be an actor,
but now he's this amazing,
um,
addiction specialists and has his master's in psychology and works in this,
uh,
Rehab.
And uh,
he's a a Neanderthal,
but he communicates well and uh,
he makes,
he's just a,
I feel like,
you know,
I'm my best self when I'm with him.
So I hate that I made it about a man.
But I did hear we are progress to guy.
We'll try another one.
Uh,
music,
uh,
Walker came into my mind,
my son Walker,
because I finally,
he won't,
he hates Mommy's singing.
He hates frozen,
hates it all.
But I got him to sit down at the piano with me.
I just shut my piano from New York to my new house in La.
And,
uh,
I got him to sit with me and you know,
you can't tell a kid,
you can't tell my son to do something.
He has to find it on his own.
Otherwise he's like,
but,
um,
we started writing a little song on the piano together and uh,
we,
we titled it and um,
okay.
It was called,
what was it called,
the fire firehouse or something.
I don't know.
Anyway,
it was a lot life scary base notes cause he's into zombies and Werewolf.
But um,
but that was music to me cause I've been waiting to have like a moment where I
could somehow inspire him with my musicality.
I love that
theater,
uh,
home theater,
Tom to me,
no matter what has happened in my career,
ups and downs,
I always can go back and I end up falling into wonderful show.
Whether it's hugely successful or not.
I have this experience with a cast and community and
you know,
recording music is sort of more of more solitary experience in theater is
family.
And,
um,
so yeah,
home
and time.
Time t.
I.
M.
E.
Yeah.
Time.
Okay.
MMM.
I'm blanking.
Time.
Time for me.
His age maybe.
Uh,
yeah,
the man wants me to have a baby and I'm like,
just forget it man.
Sled.
So it's time,
like is there enough time?
And if there is,
do I even want to do that with this time or do I want to travel and have a life
now?
Um,
so it's kind of about the,
the clock ticking time.
I love it.
I lied.
Last one.
Joy.
Yeah.
Joy is jumping on the train is the trampoline that I built my house jumping with
both boys.
Total release of energy.
Just
jumping on a trampoline.
It's like so much fun and I love it.
Yeah,
I love it.
And with that,
I'd love to turn over to the audience.
We have some mics in the middle.
Anybody want to come up and ask a question?
Oh,
we already have one.
Excellent.
It's funny you have the mix.
You probably can just ask me.
I probably won't even need this.
Hi there.
My name is Shannon.
Um,
first of all,
I just want to make a comment before,
um,
thank you for coming out and I just want to tell you that,
I grew up like,
just so looking up to you,
I lived in Arizona and like I'm sure we all like listen to you and maybe didn't
get to see you on Broadway and it was so cool cause you came here to the Greek
is your first time I think performing and I came and saw you and it was awesome
because you,
you were so real.
I loved even just the times in between the music more than like your actual
singing.
So it's cool to see you like to be honest,
like reshape that.
It was.
So I just say like I'm sure you in case you don't hear it enough cause you said
about the social and I'm sure there are people saying good and bad but like keep
being like you and authentic and real cause like thank you.
We'll do respect that.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Um,
now we'll get to my question.
So I'm,
I'm always fascinated by like how people prepare for roles and so I'd love to
hear about when you prepared,
how was it like preparing for like Maureen and Alpha Ba and that time in your
life versus preparing for like Liz,
which was like,
you're kind of come back to New York and maybe that character reflected more of
like you or I don't know,
I'm just maybe guessing.
Yeah.
And then how you prepare for like your album,
like how does it like juxtapose the preparation for like a character versus
like,
Eh,
well there's technical preparation,
which if it involves music,
then there's like the singing aspect.
Literally this,
the,
the athleticism of what that entails and preparing that,
which means the teacher I told you about it means like treating myself.
Like if it,
like if you're going to run the marathon,
you wouldn't go run 26 miles out of nowhere.
Right?
You build up.
So I do all this preparation.
I meet with her,
we go through all the music,
we pick all the things like,
oh,
that's going to be hard on a matinee.
And like I w I start singing,
um,
a certain amount of time,
literally time myself,
15 minutes a day for a week,
and then I start to move it up and all of a sudden my boys gets bigger and the
range gets bigger.
So,
and so I,
I treat that like an athlete.
Um,
and then as far as characters go,
it's changed because,
um,
I feel like I have more of a technique and a process as I've gotten older.
When I was younger,
I used to kind of just throw it out there.
Um,
but,
uh,
um,
how do I prepare?
Um,
I,
it's more to me about the words less about worrying about like how does it feel
to wear green makeup or,
you know,
um,
I mean I went and watched the wizard of Oz and like watched,
Martha,
Margaret Hamilton and,
but that was just to kind of get some cool ideas to,
to play off of and a fun cackle and her laugh,
you know,
whatever.
But for the most part it's about the language,
the words,
um,
knowing them in such a way,
that it's,
it's like song in a way to me so that I can,
it's like jazz so I can just be in the moment and,
and riff off of that.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
It's about being,
knowing that so well that you can just be open and receive.
Um,
so,
um,
I'm not doing any good.
Am I giving you a good explanation of that and then that was great.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh yes.
Uh,
so when you are in the middle of,
of a run on Broadway or something,
what is your daily routine like?
What's it really like?
Are you one of those people that rolls out of bed at noon and then I was worried
cause you work late.
Right?
But what,
what does that really like?
I'd like to get a picture of,
okay,
prove it.
Life pre baby and then there's postmate well I was also going to secondarily,
I'm,
I'm sure it was different now than it was when we are doing rent.
Yeah,
no,
it's sleep.
It's sleep,
sleep,
sleep is the best.
Healing for a voice,
first of all.
So as much sleep as possible always.
But sometimes you can't.
And if you're nervous you don't sleep well either like the night before.
But when you're in like a routine,
I,
I come home and watch a movie.
I'm,
I am,
I wound up so I get home and I'm up late because I still can't go to sleep.
I just did it performance so that adrenaline is still wearing off.
So then yeah,
sleep in.
I steam all the time.
I'm like a big steam so I will sit and like in a shower,
I'm not good for California,
waste a lot of water,
but like steam,
I vocalize,
um,
you know,
and,
and then make my way over to the theater.
But with the,
the child is just changed it because all of a sudden
and just,
I couldn't,
I couldn't get the sleep,
I couldn't get the,
everything was just,
it was just thrown up in upheaval.
But I ended up,
I feel like I ended up enjoying myself more on stage.
Now I have a child because I'm like,
well,
I can't be perfect.
So you know,
what can I do?
He had a fever and I'm trying to be a good mom.
So I get up there and I,
and then I ended up doing better because I'm more relaxed because I just throw
caution to the wind as opposed to like I work,
I warmed up for 25 minutes and I didn't drink any wine and I didn't smoke any
cigarettes and I'm perfect.
Perfect,
perfect.
And then I still miss the note.
Oh my God.
You know,
so now I'm like,
I'm more of a human being and,
um,
I,
I enjoy myself more.
That's great.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Other one?
Yes.
Oh,
first off,
congratulations on your album.
I,
as another parent,
I really enjoyed the cinnamon and perfect story.
Thank you.
Um,
now it's more like a story on myself because when I,
after I heard you singing,
defying gravity and wicked,
um,
it inspired me to start singing lessons because I have no theater background.
I was singing background.
I'm a total geek,
but I started taking private assists a couple of years.
I even started a course here at work.
Some of the members are here and just sick.
I've always wanted to sing,
but I've never felt as inspired as I did when I heard you sing defying gravity.
And I just wanted it to be able to sing along with that.
And my singing instructors also started off trying to teach me how to sing.
Kind of like you the whole belt by shouting.
Yeah.
Which is a lot like your healthy,
healthy shouting.
Exactly.
Without destroying my truck.
Well,
cause like children scream all the time and they never walk around with
Laryngitis.
So they do it in a way that's very free.
So that,
that's the thought process.
Not like screaming.
It's that idea that you call cross at the playground,
a friend.
You're like,
okay,
Hey John,
it's the same thing.
Yeah.
That's how I think of it.
And I,
and I would listen to the Shaka Khan and Aretha Franklin and actually mimic them
all the time to figure out,
well how are they doing that?
And uh,
so the best
way to learn,
I think is to emulate people.
And then because we are who we are,
it'll never be them.
It will still be unique and true to us.
So you'll,
you know,
anyway,
I'm sorry I cut you off.
No,
not at all.
I just want to let you know how your singing has touched me.
Oh,
thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much.
So what are you singing in the choir?
What do you guys,
what kind of music?
We kind of sing everything.
Um,
we,
it was like summertime,
we sing this new music.
Oh,
fun.
Yeah,
that's great.
I actually miss being in a choir.
Well maybe,
uh,
if you would like to sing in a choir.
I'm just,
I've just connecting dots here as the moderator.
It feels like opportunities a bad,
very out of practice.
Now with the four part harmony and everything.
Is it,
it's,
it's coed.
It's obviously,
yeah,
it's very cool.
Oh,
so I have something I've been wondering ever since I saw in chanted.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
at this point you had,
you know,
very well established yourself,
both in terms of your acting and singing prowess.
So it surprised me seeing you in a musical movie role without a song and the
whole movie.
So,
uh,
do you have any thoughts on,
well it wasn't written as a singing part and so I actually was so flattered
because I was like,
I know I'm an actress.
I'm not just a singer,
you know,
so I was happy and relieved to not have to worry about saying cause a lot of
times it's,
you know,
it's a relief not to sing.
Um,
or to worry about having it all there so that I was happy about that.
But once I was in it,
they wrote something and then it ended up just being superfluous cause they were
trying too hard.
Dave wrote a whole song for me and the prints at the end,
James Marsden and it got cut and he'd do it too.
I was so excited.
He was like,
this is totally got ending up on the cutting room floor.
I was like,
no,
it's not.
It's awesome.
He's like,
there's no reason for the song to be in this movie.
They are going to totally.
But thank you for thinking of that.
But I was actually happy and I then I got to take my first day of rehearsal on
that movie.
I had to show up at a dance studio,
ballroom dance studio and dance with Patrick Dempsey and James Marsden this
close and learn.
And I'm not a dance.
People think cause I'm from Broadway,
I can dance,
I can not.
It takes them like I have to have a special um,
session with the choreography to teach me eight counts.
That's like how bad am.
But um,
just imagine having to go with those two hot guys and like stand this close and
like try to be,
ah,
it was heaven and it was how at the same time it's like,
well thank you for satisfying my curiosity.
I think everybody just had this wonderful vision in their heads.
If those two bed at exactly the same time and you have to like have your,
but you know,
it's like dirty dancing.
This is my dance space.
This is your dance phase.
You know,
he's going to like touch my on like that.
You know how he does when he like Patrick Swayze doesn't thing,
you know?
And so now she's like tickled by it.
That's how it felt.
It's all,
just take a moment and take that in for you know what I'm talking about.
Right.
And then we,
okay.
Oh yeah.
We got an enthusiastic,
um,
any other questions?
We have time for one or two more.
Anybody.
Oh,
look at that.
Okay.
Hi,
I'm Tom.
So I was wondering,
do you have a favorite song and how often does your favorite song change?
Yeah,
I don't,
cause it does change depending on how I feel.
Um,
I can tell you that the things people would think I get sick of like let it go
or define gravity.
I don't get sick of singing them.
Um,
maybe it's the creature of theater or that I am where you always looking for
something new.
Just the tiniest thing from show to show to keep it fresh.
So that's something that's an exercise that I enjoy.
So either it's a little girl on the front row and I go like,
oh,
I'm going to sing,
let it go to her today.
She'd never saw a concert or I sing it to my son or I think of a new melody
because I'm sick and I have to like come up with something different because I
can't hit the high notes.
So then I'm like,
oh,
that was cool.
You know,
whatever it is,
I give myself those exercises so that can be fun.
Um,
but there's not,
it changes depending on the,
the day.
Really.
That's the cool thing about music is like what you bring to it.
The song kind of unfolds differently.
Um,
I used to sing both sides now Joni Mitchell,
and that was a great song that would sort of
just [inaudible] um,
reveal itself to me differently every time I sang it,
depending on what perspective I had,
you know,
so that was nice.
I love it.
We hosted you in the Joni Mitchell room without even knowing this.
Yeah.
She hears the conference room we were in.
It was old Joni Mitchell.
Really?
Yeah.
Look at that.
Everybody.
Um,
I know we have to wrap up because people have to get to their,
their next,
uh,
meetings.
Unfortunately in the workday,
although I'm sure everybody would like to stay here for another hour.
Yeah.
Um,
if,
if you could think of
one piece of advice that you received that you'd want to share with all of us
today,
like what's the thing that always sticks out in your mind?
Piece of advice.
I don't know.
Is it helpful?
And in this arena,
I guess it could be in any,
in life,
Serena.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
It's just,
I feel like
nobody's looking for a copy or clown of somebody else.
So as much as we want to be like other people and admire their people,
the more we figure out what makes us completely unique,
that will be the most desired thing,
whether it's in the arts or it's in business or,
um,
so when you find that thing that sets you apart,
that's the thing that's gonna get you,
make you more desirable and,
and successful.
So look,
one more younger.
We think we should be like other people,
you know?
And it's not till we realize that is,
if we're is authentic as we can possibly be,
that eventually that will you,
you will reveal yourself to the world.
That's awesome.
Um,
thank you for that and thank you for being here.
Thank you guys.
I think they gave you cds and everything and also like,
I think I'm on Google play or something like that and I believe you are in fact
downloaded on.
Oh,
gold play everybody,
please join me in thanking.
Thank you so much.
[inaudible].